hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday December 25th
2023 what's going on how
are how's it going I'm actually
recording this on Tuesday December
26th the day after Christmas you boss
called you in you went to work cuz he
has by the
Bulls you think
about killing him staring him in the
[__]
dumpster but you know that you will get
caught but imagine the
freedom for 25 to 30 minutes before the
cops show
up then you wonder what do I do
now I can't do time in prison I'll get
[__] in the ass during the
arraignment so you grab a [__]
broomstick and you run at the
cops later on it's declared suicide by
police officer all right anyways that's
dark it's the day after Christmas some
people like it some people
don't I had a little bit of the I had a
little bit of the holiday
Blues you know you start going to the
same holiday par parties every year
people are getting older empty nesters
[__] you know start looking around
the party a couple old people you're
like H I wonder if this is their last
Christmas party right and then you got
like what am I doing what am I doing
eggnog let's be happy let's be happy
um I'm one of those weirdos that I get
elated after I mean I love the holidays
for my kids but like after the holidays
like now I feel like this's finally a
vacation ation because you know you got
all the [__] Christmas parties you
got to see everybody you got to call
everybody you got to send cards you got
to FaceTime you got me see look they're
holding up the thing you got
right um and this really is like the one
time of year where you know you
everybody just kind of shuts it down
even the [__]
sociopaths that just drive the
population the whole [__] year to
work a little longer a little harder for
a little less so every quarter they can
show that they're continuing to make a
profit
uh oh [__] Billy jimar dude I'm
turning the [__]
corner I didn't have any
desserts essentially this whole year I
had a couple to a tree here or there
went off the rails a little bit when I
had some butterscotch pudding at this
fancy [__] restaurant even though I
just wanted the Swiss Smiths I did that
back in in August and that [__] me up
for like a month until I uh I got it
back under control but I didn't I didn't
mess with anything and I'm feeling good
I didn't put on the holiday pounds I'm
actually taking weight off and I know
what you guys are thinking you're
probably thinking Bill how are you doing
it I'm doing it the same way everybody
in Hollywood's doing it right oh oh oh
oh
zic is that a pain in my
pancreas um
if you don't know the O'Reilly Auto
Parts song that joke didn't make any
sense as far as like the
melody no they actually oh oh oh oh
zamic guys don't take that [__] all
right don't there's only one way to lose
weight
suffer that's the the safest and
healthiest [__] way to do it if
you're in the [__] bathroom stall
like a godamn junkie
you know sitting in your bathroom stall
[__] shooting up like you're Sid or
[__] Nancy you're not in a punk band
right you're not going to kill your
girlfriend and then commit suicide you
just had too many
burgers all right start the day
off rub one out no start the
day start the day off room temperature
lemon juice you drink that [__] right
I'd go brush my teeth too cuz the lemon
every day that'll that'll eat away the
enamel of your teeth right which is
basically the point I'm making here is
you can't have your cake and eat it
literally you're not going to go around
eating [__] pork chops in a slice of
cake and then just go shoot yourself you
know in the thigh or whatever the the
thigh gap that you want and then you're
going to drop weight you know cuz I
don't have an appetite now there's
something [__] up about that all right
you have to supper supper you have to
suffer like
Jesus on the cross except you do it on
an elliptical and you're not nailed to
it you can get off it after 30 minutes
all right so no matter how much the
elliptical sucks or eating a salad sucks
you know you're not nailed to a piece of
wood I mean if that ever
happened right you know I saw this thing
recently on uh Instagram because I don't
read you know we need to normalize not
reading
um anyway I I was watching this this
video and uh it was this really smart
guy talking about
[__] his you know knowledge of the
universe and the out outer space and all
of that [__]
right no it was not Neil degrass
Tyson who I still maintain is an average
scientist okay until I see that guy talk
to another scientist and make that guy
go wow Neil I never thought of that
before other than that he's just
explaining the universe to [__]
like me and of course we're going to be
impressed that's like if you don't play
any musical instrument and somebody
comes over to your house picks up a
ukulele and
goes you're going to have an ear to ear
grin like oh my
God did DD van alen just come back from
the dead and pick up a ukulele in my
[__]
foer right but if you you know I'm just
saying I want to see that guy impress
another
scientist
um anyway so this was some other
guy okay sort of an indie scientist he's
not is is like where where Neil degrass
is like a [__] pop scientist you know
what I mean he's selling out the staple
center right talking about now if I do
this and I add salt yeah it's going to
foam up and we're all like
wow is he
magic I thought David Blaine was amazing
holy
[__] um so this guy's explaining the
[__] universe and then understanding
the universe on the level that he did he
was talking about how he perceived
Humanity on the planet Earth it was very
small insignificant that we were like
basically these [__] uh I don't know
like maggots on a plum or something he
didn't say maggots he wasn't like
insulting but I can't remember what he
said because I'm not smart right so of
course every all the [__] Jesus
Freaks and religious
Fanatics can't [__] handle this
information so they immediately have to
say you know they throw this quote in
there that some scientist said that he
said when you once you get into science
science he was basically comparing it to
like a cup of coffee he said your first
sip of it you immediately become an
atheist and he said but at the bottom of
the cup is God so all of these Jesus
Freaks are all [__] loving that quote
but it's like hey hey
hey he said God he didn't say organized
religion he didn't say your religion
that's just a bunch of [__] that the
maggots on the plum came up with right
and how how's that been working out Wars
torture rape right is the bottom of the
of the cup when you find [__] God
that's nailing some hippie to a
[__] steak whatever the hell they did
I don't think it
is is that having wars with other
[__] people because how how Bill we
get it we get it that's all I'm saying
it's just just [__] annoys me it
[__] annoys me these organized
religion [__] idiots walking around
so goddamn scared that they're going to
die someday it's like dude what are you
afraid you're
[Music]
dead if you're laying there dead going
oh my God I'm dead you're still
alive
anyway listen I don't pretend to know
things like Neil degrass Tyson okay I'm
just a fella here who's just trying
to enjoy the fact that my New England
Patriots with [__] zappy drove down
the field at the end of the game when
everyone thought it was going into
OT with injuries at all three levels of
our defense our best guys
out oh [__] zappy drives us down the
goddamn field beautiful back shoulder
[__] pass avoiding a rush throwing it
over the middle next thing you know
we're in field goal position the kick is
up the kick is good go [__] yourself
Bill bellich takes another step towards
Don
Schuler in that record and that's what
the [__] he
wants Jesus Christ the amount of people
calling for his job Don Schuler coached
for like another I don't know how many
[__] years let's see he coached like
into the early 90s he almost coached for
another 20 years after his last Super
Super Bowl but then again there wasn't
social
media social media I call it antisocial
media [__] bills burned me what about
the
Chargers they should they should they
should have community service cleaning
up the [__] highways for one weekend
for that complete lack of effort that
they put in against the Raiders and then
the next okay they then they achieved
what they wanted to do get rid of their
[__] coach they play literally played
flag footb
football on a nationally televised game
and we're like down like 42 to nothing
at the [__] half and they got rid of
their coach and then this week right
they [__] show
up CU old Billy redface took the [__]
bills laying like [__] 10 and a half
or something crazy and then they show up
because they don't want to get kicked
off the team now they decide to
play can you imagine the Chargers coach
on [__] Christmas
weekend but he was standing there in his
underwear right probably has charger
underwear you know he hasn't had time to
go shopping he's just trying to figure
out like what the [__] happened he's
standing there in his charger oh yeah
there it is now you're [__] trying
see this is a team I put
together the [__] I team I put together
um congratulations to the Lions winning
their first division in 30 [__] years
incredible the Steelers continuing to
beat up the Bengals no matter what the
[__] their situation
is usually get the Browns actually if
I'm going to be honest shout out to the
Packers [__] me had you guys three
and a half you can't beat the lowly
Panthers by Panthers Panthers by three
and a half got [__] on that one how
about the
Cowboys the Cowboys now were they
exposed by the Buffalo Bills I these are
the questions that I ask myself rather
than being concerned about bigger
things
um did I hear people that were Pro
Palestine shut down O'Hare Airport on
Christmas I mean who organized that the
Israelis that's got to be the dumbest
thing you could ever do to get people to
get on your
side why couldn't you be
protesting to free Palestine while
helping people with their luggage into
the airport
that's like these [__] hairy-legged
ladies whenever they get upset what do
they do they sit there fat asses down in
the [__] uh in
traffic Jesus Christ 20 minutes of that
you're ready to legalize hitting women
again I don't I I've never understood
protesting like that that doesn't like
I'm going to completely [__]
inconvenient you how about the Ravens
showing that defense still wins champ
ionships all those 49er fans you know
they're skipping around out there in
that [__] football stadium they have
I swear to God looks like a vintage
roller coaster you
know
um I had the 49ers this week I had the
Giants the Giants saved my [__] ass
how about the Dolphins finally beating a
good team for the first time this year
you know shout out to Nick croll he did
a great job he had a great g game plan
for the
Dolphins um all
right let's get on with the podcast here
people let's get on to what the [__] it
is I want to talk about this week which
is what
basically um [__] Chiefs lose I love
everybody they're so excited that the
Chiefs lose shout out to Chiefs fans you
know you win a couple of Super Bowls all
of a sudden everybody just [__] hates
you just cuz you're
winning that's like I'm telling you
that's what I'm living right now we
[__] sucked and everybody's like you
[__] suck right then we get Bill
parcels and like you still didn't win it
you [__] suck right and then we win
six out of nine Super Bowls and during
that time what a people say you
cheated now that that's
over it's [__] those six Super Bowls
what do you doing now you
[Music]
suck so Chiefs that's what's going to
happen um I would never count the Chiefs
out I don't know how many times I've
seen them um during this this time that
they've been good which I'm sure they're
labeling as a dynasty which is
ridiculous because they're not a dynasty
um you know during this run where they
are the team to knock off in the AFC I
can't tell you how many times they had a
couple of losses in the regular season
everybody's all go oh gee is this the
end is Pat Mahomes are [__] overrated
no there's still going to be a problem
in the
playoffs they just are because their
quarterback is better than your
quarterback sorry all right he I think
he's the best guy in the AFC oh by the
way what happened to [__] uh what
happened to Brock pie I bought into that
hype I bet against the [__] 49ers not
to cover the spread three [__] weeks
in a row and you know what's going to
happen this is like playing [__]
roulette red red red all right [__] it
black red
loser that's what happened to me and I
started buying into this Brock py hype
look at this I mean he's letting the
ball go before the receiver makes his
cut it's like isn't that what they all
do isn't that what the [__] you turn
around as an NFL receiver the [__]
balls right there I thought that's what
all the great ones did so I sat there
and I believed that there was another
great
party okay up until then there was
Bernard py and then there was everybody
else and I was like well maybe maybe
Brock pie maybe he's our white Bernard
pie for those of you who don't play
drums Bernard p is one of the greatest
drummers of all time one of the sickest
grooves of all time and he also claims
that he played on some of the Beatles
albums which I don't believe because
there's a consistency in all of that
playing it's all Ringo's voice so unless
he's the greatest
impressionist on drums ever I just don't
I don't think
so but then again who knows maybe they
they put a mop top [__] Fab Fab 4 wig
on him and he was able to channel it I
don't know I have no idea uh so anyway
old freckles old freckles is doing great
with something I have not been good at
for 20 years
moderation or as my mother says
everything in moderation she would
always yell at sorry I dropped the
[__] mik here she would always yell
that over everybody at the holiday
parties and ah you know I'm drinking too
much I got to lay up the cigarettes and
blah blah you know really loud chatter
and then she would yell over this
everything in
moderation and after a while we would we
would finish the sentence with her in
moderation and she would just laugh and
guess what she was right she was right
right um so I've been able to go back to
drinking coffee and only having one cup
a day I have one cappuccino and I have
it at my house because I think I make
the best one in town all right talking a
lot of [__] but I figured out my coffee
machine and I like sitting out on my
back porch you know plotting my next
move kidding that's the [__] picture
I hate the most is you know when they
when they're shooting somebody that's in
the public eye and they do that thing
where it they
uh what is what you know they're sitting
down and it's like they have like their
hand is always near their face you know
and they're never looking at the camera
they're looking they're looking to the
future you know they got like that
[__] like yeah
man I mean I like conquered everything
like what's my next challenge
oh by the
way I [__] stumbled onto a couple of
things oh and cigars I have not had a
cigar since um Thanksgiving like 33
[__] days ago but I'm having one this
afternoon with a buddy of mine and then
I'm going to have one at the Rose Bowl
and I'm only having one today and one
then and then I'm shutting it down until
the Super
Bowl all right and
then uh I think I'm going to shut it
down again until like April I'm going to
try to do like one a month or one every
other
month and just really enjoy it because I
found that having one cup of coffee a
day I enjoy it more and if I randomly
take like two days off and then have
that cappuccino oh it tastes
unbelievable but I'll tell you this this
might surprise you guys if you drink
four every day
you can't [__] taste it
anymore so my new
obsession since I saw that
cojac episode as I was calling it The
Denali Ferrari not the dino the Denali
like a [__] GMC I can't help it I'm a
truck guy right and I'm an American and
I'm not cultured when it comes to
European sports cars the dino Ferrari in
silver they made it I don't know how
like from like six 69 to 74 or something
like that it was a mid engine V6 was not
actually considered a real Ferrari they
are [__] gorgeous so I look one up
and I go you know what what if I just
bought one I drove it for a year enjoyed
it so I know the car I know what it
feels like I know what it's like to
drive the car be [__] amazing and
then I just sell
it and I started thinking like well
maybe that's what I do why don't why
don't I just buy a classic car every
year I know I'd always lose money you
drive it for one year and then you sell
it before it really gets a chance to
take r i mean [__] everything from a
[__] old school Ferrari to like a
Buick Grand National I mean I love the
83 cutless personally like some of the
80s cars that I always loved Thunderbird
turbo CP coupe right
87 um in
silver um not a lot of cars in the
80s
uh what else
you know I'm really starting to like the
Mopar [__] I was never a Mopar guy but
anyway Ford Galaxy 65 Riv [__] uh
boattail
Riviera you know 67 Cadillac El Dorado
just [__] just drive them for a year
you sell them you lose a bit of [__]
money is anybody out there doing that
because I don't want to be this guy that
has like
[__] you
know a bunch of [__]
cars and they're all going to leak and
they're all a [__] pain in the ass
but like I love them there there are a
few places out here where you can just
rent them I think I'm just going to do
that like once a month you rent one you
have it for the weekend it's [__]
amazing and the door doesn't quite close
right but who gives a [__] CU you're
giving it back on Sunday
right people I'm just thinking out loud
here um there was something else though
I I did want to talk about before that
is uh
look got Roundup oh
yeah someone was telling me that these
fast food places finally have to [__]
admit that they're using
Roundup and their
[__] fertilizer and [__] like I don't
know I don't know that [__] is like
agent orange for for
civilians still still using it so I
don't know what to do man I saw this
thing where it was saying that you could
[__] uh use baking soda on all your
fruits and vegetables to get the
pesticides off it uh which pesticide I
they are they necessary I I would think
so to try to keep all of these people
alive I don't know then you see these
other people you just take a little bit
toothpaste and some lemon juice and you
create this mixture you just go out and
you paint your plants and it's [__]
fine which I think works good for a
backyard
garden but if you're commercial
farming you know that's a lot of
toothbrushes no
all right Bill degrass Tyson needs to
shut the [__] up I really have no idea I
mean for at least the last seven minutes
I've had no idea what I'm talking about
you know but it's the day after
Christmas I did real well on
Christmas I did you know I got some nice
sweaters this is all dad [__] um and
then I I got uh I got a new snare drum
and I got a snazzy
jacket I mean that's enough for me you
know jacket I got some
underwear the older you get the more you
appreciate new underwear and socks new
socks new socks you show up to work you
know that chick you want to bang is like
what's going on with you what' you do
this
weekend and you and then you play at koi
oh wouldn't you like like to know right
and next thing you know you're banging
her right you bent her over the hood of
her own car and you're banging around in
the parking
lot and you can't figure out what feels
better banging her or those new socks on
your [__]
feet it's a it's a
push um anyway Christmas went off
without a hitch we got all the presents
down there we did all that all right I'm
back I don't know want to happen I
always forget to put it on airplane mode
when I'm recording here
um so anyway yeah the
uh the Christmas went off without a
hitch fantastic kids Lov their gifts
they were ridiculously
excited and
uh you know I didn't put him through
like we used to do this thing in in when
I was growing up like one
year my siblings we got up and we
[__] went downstairs
or was it upstairs I can't
remember I can't remember probably
upstairs yeah we went
upstairs hey we moved around a lot okay
and we just opened all the [__] gifts
really quickly and my parents were like
what the [__] we did all of that work
and it's over in two seconds so
then they started doing this thing you
can't open them until after we have
breakfast and then it was we have to go
to church and then we're going to going
to have breakfast and then they would
just sit there and they'd have their
[__] coffee and just enjoy just
torturing us just torturing us we like
Jesus [__]
Christ and they're like not yet we're
having our coffee you know what I mean
I'm telling you they got off on
it so now I go the other way I I'm sort
of a little bit like I'm the I I
definitely go like hey one present at a
time so everyone can see what you
got and uh you know and also we can see
who gave who what so in the end when you
got to do all the FaceTime [__] you know
you don't say like the wrong thing and
still this year somebody called up and
said hey how did your son enjoy the gift
I got I said I don't know man what did
you get I don't know I have no idea like
90 people send this [__] [__] I got a
bunch of relatives I I don't know and
then they described it oh yes they loved
it and then we ended it and then that
was it and everything went
fine everything went
fine um oh God damn it now I got the
[__] thing off and I can't go to
check my emails to read the
uh to read the
goddamn advertising for the week right
so now I got to take this
off technology does it make your life
easier
yes in certain areas I would think so I
have no idea I don't know what I'm
talking about here all right here we go
oh MMP content oh there it is there it
is would you look at
that wait do I have no reads for the
week oh my God I got to stop [__]
around I really have to stop [__]
around when I'm I'm I'm
doing the advertising I got to do some
more straight reads no offense to gay
people I got to do more straight reads
because I keep getting [__] in
trouble
you know it's not that I just felt he
was
suggesting um all right let's do uh
let's do the [__] let's do the the ad
ad reads the ad reads LLY LLY LLY get
your ad reads here all right MMP content
1224 Bill Good emails inbox was a little
light this week so there are only three
oh Jesus what are you guys out there
celebrating [__] Christmas
is that what it
is all right let's read him okay all
right you guys you guys not going to
send me emails it's going to be a
[__] short podcast on the necessity
of
starving hey scrotum
Dome I resent that I have a nice [__]
head uh I don't have a [__] wrinkly
ball bag of a head um my neck's getting
there though I wanted to get your advice
or your perspective on something I am an
SL performer but I have a nice day
job tell you that's a rough situation
and often other performers in my field
will look down on me because I'm not
doing the starving artist thing in some
cases other artists have taken even
taken a Sharpie and drawn on my
car well you know what you need better
friends well you never said they were
friends they're just
artists well [__]
them [__] them that's the people are
idiots that there's only one way to do
things the way I'm doing things don't
[__] listen don't even listen to me
unless what I'm saying to you resonates
and [__] makes sense [__] those
people dude that is the biggest [__]
[__] move in the [__] world is when
you have a problem with another [__]
man and you go up and instead of
confronting them you You Vandal ize
their [__] car that is such a [__]
[__] move if you don't believe me
there's a zillion videos of of guys
showing ex-girlfriends destroying their
[__] cars I love when they do that
[__] when women destroy guys cars or or
their property their apartments and
stuff you know that's actually a great
sign because what she's saying is that
you know that's what that's how much she
values stuff you know what I
mean so she was going to [__] one way
or another she was going to cost you a
ton of money so you might as well rip
the Band-Aid
off you know um I look forward to a
future where women are actually charged
with destruction of property regard oh
he cheated on me great that doesn't mean
you get to wreck a [__] $440,000 car
because you're upset you know why don't
you take a little bit of responsibility
and and and and and
[__] you know take it on yourself
that you were dating an
[__] right there's plenty of nice
guys that liked you you didn't like them
you tried to land the guy with the fancy
[__] car that smelled good that all
the women wanted to bang and guess what
you found out you were just another
notch in the bed post lesson learned go
find a nice guy that's not what they do
that's not what they do they [__] go
attack your car
[Music]
um anyway this person goes on to say
what these people fail to realize this
is the guy talking about I guess the
artist drawing on his car what these
people fail to realize is that I'm a
Serial Dreamchaser I came from
workingclass parents and I buddy you
don't have to explain yourself to
me you know you bought a car with money
that you earned by [__]
working all right people shouldn't go up
and draw on it cuz they don't like the
way that you're trying to a I don't know
make a career out of being a painter or
whatever the [__] it is you're doing but
we'll we'll continue I came from a
working class from workingclass parents
and I was a millionaire by the time I
was 26 I feel like if I could achieve my
dreams uh wait a minute and I was a
millionaire by the time I was 26 that's
[__] amazing I feel like if I could
achieve my dreams once I could do it
again but they don't see that addition
if we all have to work day jobs whether
that's waiting tables or barking tickets
for comedy clubs I'd rather do a job
that I enjoy additionally dopamine is
important for creativity so I'd rather
be happy during the day so that I could
come up with ideas um you seem wise
beyond your years you know unless you
were in sex trafficking I don't know how
you made your [__] money you're not a
slum
Lord um I stand behind you anyway still
I could see the Counterpoint there's a
Will Smith quote where he says you
shouldn't have a plan B because it
distracts you from plan
a uh and clearly he didn't have another
plan when he marched up on that arar
stage well yeah I mean I look I'm not
relationships are [__] complicated
I'm not going to step into that
Labyrinth
[Music]
uh I mean from afar he should have had a
plan B before it even got to the [__]
Oscars cuz I like Will Smith you
know
anyway uh but he didn't and he stayed
with plan a
so that's I mean whatever I mean Hey
listen we all do whatever the [__] we is
that we that you know we all I'm trying
to be less [__]
judgmental I really am you know what I
mean I'm really trying not I don't know
what the [__] other people are going
through I I realize that I'm an [__]
so what am I going to do I mean it's
easy to sit back and be like he you know
what this person should have done I
can't say this people should not go
around drawn on other people's cars
anyway without veering too far from this
quote I think the point is
that uh there's probably something to
not living a life that's too comfortable
such that it distracts you from your
real goals all right here's something
that I'll tell you I'll tell you because
I don't have a co-host to tell me to
shut the [__] up um just because
somebody is successful doesn't mean they
know
anything all right and there's this
thing that I've noticed with people
after they're
successful is that after they make it
they and then they go to tell their
story they then put a whole bunch of
[__] mustard on it and I knew in that
moment when I walked into that room
either I was going to get this gig or my
life was over and it's in those moments
you have to have the courage and all of
that [__] stroke in your own dick
horseshit
um this is what happens this is what
really happens is you go after a unless
you're a [__] lunatic and you're
literally trying to cross people off
your list and you're a [__] sociopath
whatever
okay
um most most of us you go after a dream
because it like you connect with it and
it makes you feel good doing it right
for me was playing drums music but I
realized that I I just didn't have the
gift but I always made people laugh and
gradually I gravitated
towards like standup comedy
now I definitely wanted to make it I
definitely wanted to succeed I
definitely wanted to be a famous
comedian but I didn't have any sort of
plan Beyond sign up for as many places
that will put you on stage as possible
and then it was just okay now I'm one of
the better open micers I can now get
paid and I became a host and then a host
like oh I'll become like a feature and
then you become a feature and then you
you become like a headliner and then
you're doing C rooms and then you move
up to B rooms and a rooms and blah blah
blah blah blah but there was no
like
um like this
rigid like I have one [__] plan in
life and and and like this is the only
[__] way to do things all right there
is no one way to do things and you
really got to watch out for [__]
egomaniacs that are just sitting there
stroking their own I mean believe me
believe me there's a bunch of them in my
[__] business and it's amazing just
sitting there watching them talking
about
themselves um and keep repeating the
same stories over and over again and
then what's amazing is gradually
everyone else starts saying about them
what they were saying about themselves
it's like this [__] hypnosis
thing
so
um I I I wouldn't you know I wouldn't
listen to Will
Smith okay okay that guy has a lot of
[__] [__] he needs to work on he's
wildly successful in some areas not so
successful in other areas guess what
just like me okay so there's a lot of
[__] luck in lot of [__] luck
involved getting somewhere so there
there is none of that all right what you
should be doing is like if you being an
artist is something that really fills
you up and makes you feel good that's
why you should be doing it this whole
[__] thing of like I'm going to have
my own gallery and and I'm going to fake
my own death so my [__] posters are
going to be worth more money and then
I'll come back they like oh [__] he's
back and then all of that [__] that's
for corporate
[__] so um yeah anyway let me get back
to this
uh this person says I think there's a
point there blah blah blah blah still
overall I wanted to get your perspective
on this and whether it's better to be a
starving artist if you don't have to be
no I was never a starving
artist I was never I
[__] I worked for like another two
years when I could have not had a day
job just paying off all of my debt
because I knew I was moving to New York
City and I was [__] terrified how
expensive it was so I wanted to go down
there I had no credit card debt I paid
off my student loans I mean I didn't
move down there until I was like 27 I
mean I was considered old to be a new
guy coming to town
and um I started late I did everything
that you know they say you know oh you
know if you wait too long to start
you're not going to make it you know all
of these [__]
rules I remember the butcher giving me
bad advice I don't know everybody wants
to be the star sitting there with a
bloody apron cutting up [__] pork
chops giving me
advice negative feedback on getting into
Show Business so
um I would say be careful listening to
other people if they listen to you and
it makes sense if it [__] makes sense
if it feels good in your gut then I
would listen to it but don't ever listen
to somebody just cuz they got a big
house and a shiny [__] car you don't
know anything about them all right if
you want to see something [__] insane
is you just watch how people
like like one of the big things to learn
in life
is
um is
recognizing that you're talking to a
narcissist all right or like a
sociopath and there's little things over
the years that I've been able to you
know I grew up around [__] like that so
I'm but I wasn't able
to break the code until about six years
ago and now I'm really
much better at
spotting a narcissist and and um I was
looking something up the other
day no I wasn't I was on Instagram cuz
that's where I'm I'm I'm addicted to my
phone the last [__] addiction I have
to get under control everything in
moderation um sorry I had to knock that
down um that was a foam roller by the
way
um let's see narciss
ISM uh there was something that this the
these people had I can't spell this
[__] word I it's just incredible that
I look me like I can't even [__]
spell and I'm doing fine that right
there should make you feel like you're
going to be all right with your artist
dream uh
[Music]
deny
uh darvo that's it all right so they
came up with this
thing that uh it's called darvo it's an
anacronym D- a r
v it stands for deny
attack uh re uh reverse victim and
Defender and it describes a manipulative
tactive often used by abusers to avoid
taking responsibility for their actions
and shift the blame onto their victims
okay so when somebody does that doesn't
mean they're a narcissist doesn't mean
they're sociopath they're just something
like that so if somebody does something
to you you [__] call them out on it
and they [__] deny it like this is
was my
experience with this [__] with
narcissists it's like the first thing
they say is I never did
that okay and
then the next thing it becomes I'm not
going to be I'm not going to sit here
and a let you accuse me of that and it
it and then then it becomes that so I
guess that's becoming like the victim um
first is I never did that then maybe a
little bit of anger sometimes you know
if they know they're dead to rights
they'll do they'll say like well look if
I did that if I did that then I'm sorry
and it's like no you did do that and
they'll still be like well I'm I if I
don't remember I I'm being honest with
you I I don't remember but if if what
you're saying is true like that's the
best you can kind of get um there's
other things too like I noticed
um with this person they had the exact
same emotional response to if you told
them you stubbed your toe or if your
mother just died they would do this
thing where they would just kind of [__]
their head to the side and be like oh
no they would
just and it was just
something it took a while and I just
sort of noticed with this person like
they don't feel
feelings now it could be because they're
completely walled off I don't think
they're a sociopath in that instance but
you just sit there going like they
either don't feel feelings or they don't
give a [__] about anything but
themselves so that's the type of [__]
that I would say that you
know in
life you have to watch out for when
you're going after a dream okay those
people that are drawing on your
car um are are [__] and they
guarantee you would never in a million
years like honestly they they could pass
a lie detector are you an [__] for
doing that and they would say no I'm not
I'm not cuz [__] that guy cuz he's in
the corporate world and the and they're
building this whole [__] story and
then they're also buying into this [__]
and at the end of the day they're also
jealous and envious of you that if you
want to go out and get a sandwich you
can [__] afford it
um so [__] them
all
right um and if you have anybody in your
life that if you're
like if they're constantly doing [__] to
you and whenever
you you know confront them they deny
they they they
like they diminish that's another thing
I never did that or oh that wasn't that
bad oh that was just a joke they do that
[__] and you're like no it wasn't it
wasn't a joke to
me and then then what they oh jeez you
know I had no idea you're so so
sensitive oh I love the other thing like
oh I mean I I mean I can't do anything
that's one or what did I do now all of
that [__] [__] you [__] you what did I
do now [__] you on all of that [__] [__]
you on all of that [__] don't don't let
somebody do anything like that to you um
I'm acting like there's a way to get
them to
admit that they've done something wrong
the reality is you can't and what you
have to do is just slowly back away from
those people uh which is really easy to
do with a narcissist because once a
narcissist is not getting an attention
positive or negative they they just
they're in The Ether they're in the wind
you never see them again um anyway still
overall I wanted to get your perspective
on
this and whether it's better to be a
starving artist if you don't have have
to be uh how did the cushy job people in
your generation Faire Against The
Starving
Artists um it had nothing to do with
anything it had nothing to do it's a
myth that you didn't make it because you
had something to fall back on that's all
a [__] myth I'll tell you the people
that did well were gifted people that
did the work all right like I can try to
in a band all day long it's not going to
sound good I can have the you know you
got to have the gift if you have the
gift and you [__] work at it you know
and you're not an [__] because it's
also a business and people want to be
around you you're going to be successful
it has nothing to do with you know how
much money you have or don't
have and uh you
know and also just because you grow up
rich doesn't mean you don't have have a
bunch of
demons uh and that you had this easy
[__] life and everything like you
have no idea like some of these rich
kids they grow up there some of the
loneliest remember hearing like Robin
Williams like grew up and had like from
a wealthy family but his his parents
were never around and he had like this
lonely [__] childhood playing with
like his army guys and stuff I mean it
sounded you know I I wouldn't want that
childhood for the [__] money so those
are all just those are all just [__]
theories that's all they it has nothing
to do with anything um continuing on um
this person says will that always be the
case
um oh he's asking about having a cushy
job versus starving artist the success
rate will that always be a CA the case
especially in this age of social media
where cameras and editing are expensive
and regular people are being priced out
oh Jesus there's your cold corporate
side coming out a trend that's happen
happening across art and sports
today um no the what's happening is is
that corporations are not regulated at
all and they are run by people that are
not human both in my business and in any
other business and what's happening to
artists in my business and Auto Workers
Farmers you
know even just public service jobs you
name it these people are just taking and
taking and taking and taking they're
just [__] people over and they're
heartless and and what do they do they
blame us because there we haven't pushed
back we haven't been able to organize to
effectively push back on their greed so
they go well you know I mean and I
mean we haven't seen any push back we
haven't seen enough push back the
government's not doing anything to stop
us once again they blame the people that
they victimized so
um the biggest thing that you should try
to get out of life is to enjoy it all
right and there's a lot of [__] that you
will see on social media and everything
and people think that enjoying life is
having a flat screen TV on every [__]
wall of your house and having a bunch of
stuff and all of that [__] and uh and it
isn't it's having enough money where if
you want to you can sit down and [__]
take a break and have a [__] sandwich
and a nice cup of coffee it's nothing
better than that
you know I don't think but I'm an old
guy anyway good luck to you good luck to
you
um all right I will admit that one thing
that artists are being priced out I mean
that's not true I mean you can shoot a
movie on a [__] iPhone so I think I
think you'll be all right um anyway I
did get that was a little bit of a red
flag though the way you were talking
about that um I I did see a little
corporate uh Haze in the atmosphere
there all right just realized I'm the
[__] well hey buddy welcome to the
[__] world Welcome to My Life uh hey
Billy to
Toth I don't know what that means um I
have all my teeth I don't have any
cavities I've never had a cavity I don't
know what the [__] that means but if you
wanted to make make me self-conscious
about something else you have done it um
I've been bothered by a lot in my
life I've been bothered by a lot in my
life by a lot of things that have
happened to me in the
past
um that is one of the greatest sentences
I've ever read in my life that's like
was like [__] Mogul skiing Moguls
I've been bothered by a lot in my life
by a lot of things that have happened to
me in the past dude you should be
writing for [__] Dr
Seuss uh at this juncture whoa pulls out
a nice [__] $4 word there I'm doing
really well but the carryover from my
past has followed me like a fog as you
said in the Adam Driver interview yes
the
fog that's why a lot of uh adults with
childhood trauma are always moving can't
sit still and always trying to do
something else and it it it has your
mind on something else CU if you sit
still the sadness comes
in um anyways the person said recently I
had a work trip that allowed me some
time off where I was by
myself I was stuck listening to other
people's conversations and I realized
that most people complain about things
that don't matter and I had the
realization that I'm not one of them
well that's great how does that make you
an [__] that makes you enlightened
I've been bar barking about everything
wrong with the world to everyone around
me and I certainly have a billy red face
like temper I did wait a minute you
said
you said you were listening to these
people complain about things that don't
matter and I had the realization oh that
you're one of them oh I'm sorry that you
[__] I thought you meant that I'm sorry
I thought you were saying that you're
not one of them maybe I read that wrong
uh anyway so you're one of them I've
been barking about everything wrong with
The World To Everything everyone around
me and I certainly have a billy red face
like temper I did therapy and I've done
mushrooms but something clicked where I
realized I'm just adding to the noise
um that's a good name for a standup
special adding to the noise uh my
biggest problems my biggest problem is
that I've been blaming people who are
easy to blame people I rarely interact
with but know people that I don't know
and people that I make up in my
head all at the expense of the people
around me I'm 49 years old and had the
horrific realization that I've wasted so
many precious times in my life thinking
I was wrong but mostly I never spoke to
the people who were bothering me I could
never understand why I didn't get along
with the people everyone else did and
it's because I never really got to know
them this [__] me up when I
realized I'm no different and I
shouldn't expect people to like me my
new goal in life is to talk to people in
person and not in my head it's been
working well well I had that problem and
sometimes I still do is I don't go to
the person that I'm upset with because
when I was growing up uh that was not an
option or the person wouldn't listen
so then you feel hopeless and then
that's when you get like a
temper um and then that's when someone
goes well you know you can't leave until
2 o' why the [__] can't we leave until
two you know you immediately go to
that and it's just like and there's
always an easy solution like I do that
all the [__] time I still do
it the lovely Nia was talking to me
about it the other day and you know I
got to [__] work on it I have to work
on it I I uh I don't yell at people but
I [__] snap and she goes every day I
go every day she goes every day so I was
like you know what I'm going to show her
I'm going to go on a [__] streak here
just like cigars I'm not going to yell
and I I've yet to be able to not
snap before like 11 in the morning like
there's
something is it's just going to make me
[__] you know I mean I don't think
I'm yelling but other people do so I
mean I have to listen to them so you're
not alone here uh my new goal in life is
to talk to people in person not my head
it's been working well I called a friend
who I hadn't talked to in a while and I
realized I was the one who shut him out
just because I disagreed with him on
dumb [__] anyways I appreciate all the
self-help talk it definitely inspired
some of my changes hope you find peace
too Bill merry New Year well thank you
that's a very nice thing to wish for me
I hope I do tell
I think generally
speaking I'm at peace there's some stuff
still bugs
me um there's other stuff I can't
control um anyway new girl is overly
sexual and it's turning me off didn't I
just read something like this hey Billy
Gringo what are you talking about Gringo
I'll go to a [__] taco truck in order
a
tort I've been educated by my Latino
uh uh um
listeners latinx I'm not going to say
that I know why people came up with that
I've been seeing the new girl for I've
been seeing this new girl for about two
months or so we met on one of the apps
and we really hit it off in person she's
smart cute and funny generally funny not
just funny for a chick I thought I
already read this is this Deja Vu I'll
[__] read it again the only problem
is is that she's way too overly sexual
with me and it's really starting to
annoy SL turn turn me
off this is when women come in and they
just go she sex she what [__] bu but
if a guy wanted to bang all the time
it'd be like she is not a [__]
Outlet whatever the hell they say stop
using her as a [__] dick
blanket um that's a thing by the way a
dick blanket and if you didn't get one
for Christmas I'll have the link on the
podcast uh trust me I'm no prude but I
but literally 247 texts txting and
sending me RIS a photos I did read this
before whatever I'll give you a
different take while this is the the DVD
extras while I'm at work uh sending me
all this stuff it's starting to give me
an
ick yeah you're at work you don't want
to look at her [__] clam you're
trying to focus here hope you're not
working with heavy
machinery uh at first it was fun or
whatever but holy cow how can anyone be
this horny all the [__] time I feel
like an old person but Jesus leave
something to the imagination yeah she
you know she's [__]
uh she's doing like an autopsy on her
[__] puss um I'm starting to feel
less attracted to her because using my
male brain I now think she's some type
of easy [__] and most likely does this a
lot with new guys well who gives a [__]
if you using your male brain you're a
guy listen all of these [__] broads
that you didn't want to bang anyway okay
[__] mind [__] all men that the way
that they think and look at women is
completely [__] up all right it's not
completely [__] up it's just [__] up
it's not completely [__] up so
sometimes you are right not to mention
the way they look at men is [__]
ridiculous
um so anyway uh I this person says I
hate thinking this way but it's probably
true am I wrong for thinking this way
Bill no you're not
anyway Merry Christmas and go [__]
yourself no you're not I mean what is
she what is you're at [__] work and
she she's sending all these
[__] [__] pictures and all of this
[__] wants the [__] all the
time um yeah I would say that there's
something going on there if you can't go
a work day without her sending you a
picture of her tits she's either
massively insecure that you're going to
leave I don't know what but like there's
a lot going on there
probably and
uh
you know you have to decide if you want
to deal with it or not and that's just a
human thought do I want to take on
because you're going to take on her
problem so you're going to have to deal
with
them
um I don't know Jesus Christ and then if
you break up with her she's the next guy
she's going to want to [__] even more
you just attract what you fear and then
he's going to leave because he's going
to be like thinking the same
thing you know she'll be sending like
[__] stick a camera up her ass or
something who knows what she's going to
do I don't know I'm just glad I'm not
dating anymore I can tell you that uh PS
I've been
watching uh your special since I was 12
years old and I am now 24 safe to say
your comedy help me help shape my sense
of humor and outlook on life keep on
rocking you Ginger pube [__] um I think
the big takeaway There Was You said you
know which put me in my male
brain
um yeah there's nothing wrong with that
and there's nothing wrong with looking
at a woman that wants to bang all the
time and is sending you [__] pictures
thinking that maybe she's a little
promiscuous that maybe you know once she
[__] your dick raw and you're not
giving it to her every night whatever
she's getting out of all of this [__]
she's going to need to get it elsewhere
and you're just gonna it's going to be a
big [__] I mean that that's not the
mother of your
kids
okay I know in a defense of that lady
IES is is the father of your children
sending you [__] close-ups of his
[__] dick and balls right now does
that make you say I want to have a kid
with this
person I don't know maybe it does I have
no
idea it's it's definitely a uh it's
definitely a different world so anyways
that is the podcast everybody I think
that was a fun one I think we all
learned a little something you know
patting myself on the back you know I
think I gave you guys some
gems you know we'll have to to run it
past Neil degrass Tyson I'm sure he's
rolling his eyes you know I do like the
way he has his fro it's very like I
think it's like a nod to Albert Einstein
there is
something with super smart people that
they got to their hair has to be a
little like attention grabbing to just
straight up bed head like [__] uh
Albert Einstein so you know that they're
they're
so they're so busy figuring out the
universe they don't have time to go to
the
barber um this was all said by a bald
man who [__] went to summer school um
all right that's it everybody go [__]
yourselves I will check in on you in uh
in a couple of days all right enjoy your
time off eat salads get on an elliptical
[__] turn it around don't [__]
inject yourself with [__] there's going
to be a price to pay oh oh oh is that
cancer sir all right I'll see you